I'm Mary Helen Bowers,
founder of Ballet Beautiful Fitness.
I danced with New York
City Ballet for 10 years.
Ballet Beautiful is really born
from my experience as
a professional dancer
and that whole life
experience of being a dancer,
which is so incredibly physical,
where you are using your
body to express your art.
And I had to learn,
and it took a lot of trial and error
for me to figure out the best system
to take care of my body,
to prevent injury, to feel my strongest,
my leanest, and my best.
Once I left the company, I
took a break from dancing.
I needed time where I
wasn't in a dance studio,
where I didn't have that pressure
to look a certain way,
to perform a certain way.
And when I wanted to start working out
I had gained weight, my body had changed.
I also didn't want to go
back into a ballet studio,
I felt self-conscious.
So I started picking up
with my old exercises.
I would do 45 minutes a day.
And my body started to change.
I got leaner and really
all of my ballet muscles
kind of came back into use.
And with that process, my
whole body began to change.
I started sharing my workout with friends.
All of our clients have really been built
through word of mouth.
One of the first Victoria's Secret Angels
that I worked with was Miranda Kerr,
who is a long-time client and a very
dear friend of mine.
We're still working together today.
And it's been fun to train
with people like Miranda
and like Lily Aldridge.
Through having a baby,
through, maybe, a second pregnancy.
For some people it's
through multiple seasons
of doing a show like Victoria's Secret,
or a big film, or runway moment.
But it's been really
exciting, too, for me,
to take these women through
some really momentous
moments in their careers.
And be there to support them,
to help them feel strong,
to help them feel confident,
and perform at their best level as well.
With the Angels, they're
training really, really, hard.
I'm using ballet inside the workout,
but I'm thinking of it as
a really, really focused,
crazy, I want the deepest burn.
I want to give them the biggest impact.
We're trying to make their
abs as toned as possible,
to make their butts as
lifted and toned as possible,
to give them sleek definition
through their legs.
And beautiful posture
and strength to hold,
those wings for example,
which really weigh a lot.
So it's not that I'm giving them a workout
that someone else couldn't do.
But certainly we are doing a really
intensified version of the program.
A mutual friend that I had danced with,
with New York City Ballet,
connected me with Natalie.
She was in town.
She was looking for a new trainer
and for somebody to help
prepare her for "Black Swan."
She danced really seriously until
she was about 12 or 13, when
her acting career took off.
So we had to kind of bring her up to speed
with her dancing.
"Black Swan," I think, played a huge role
in bringing ballet into the spotlight,
making it cool, making it hip
and relevant in pop culture.
And of course, Natalie's
role in that was huge.
And I was so fortunate to have been
such a big part of that film.
And it also brought ballet fitness
into the press, into I
think, the sort of lexicon
of the everyday woman.
You don't have to be a professional dancer
or to have trained your
body for a dozen years
to experience ballet, to
bring it into your home.
You feel better, you have more energy.
Your body feels stronger.
You start to see results.
It's really, really motivating.
And as you get going, you
can build that momentum
to make fitness a more
regular part of your life,
a larger part of your life.
You can prioritize.
And it takes some work to say,
"I'm gonna carve this
time out just for me."
Don't wait for life to be perfect
because it's busy and it's messy,
and you just have to start where you are.